es este sistema de ecuaciones lineales
consistente o inconsistente y bueno
tengo aquí nuestros ecuaciones lineales
y lo que me gustaría preguntarme es qué
significa ser consistente y qué
significa ser inconsistente y bueno
vamos a hacer un poco de memoria un
sistema es consistente cuando tiene al
menos una solución cuando tiene al menos
la solución puede ser una o una
infinidad de soluciones pero al menos
tiene una solución y eso significa que
se intersectan y un sistema es
inconsistente cuando no tienen solución
no existe una solución o dicho de otra
manera no se intersectan y vamos a ver
los tres posibles casos que pueden pasar
cuando tenemos dos líneas rectas en un
plano cartesiano entonces este es mi eje
de las x esta es mi guel así es y si yo
tengo que mis dos rectas se intersectan
entonces existe una solución a este
sistema o dicho de otra manera este
sistema es un sistema consistente porque
existe al menos una solución porque
existe una solución es decir
se intersectan el otro caso que
podríamos tener es el siguiente que
tengo mi eje de las x aquí tengo mi que
de las yes y voy a suponer que tengo la
misma recta tengo esta recta de aquí y
por otro lado tengo esta misma recta que
tengo aquí las cuales también se
intersectan en una infinidad de
soluciones porque se intersectan en una
infinidad de puntos por lo tanto tienen
al menos una solución porque tienen una
infinidad de soluciones y esto quiere
decir que también es un sistema
consistente y cómo se vería un sistema
que es inconsistente bueno dos rectas
que nunca se tocan es decir no hay
solución estás rectas que nunca se tocan
se conocen como rectas paralelas
entonces vamos a dibujar dos rectas
paralelas aquí esta recta que yo tengo
aquí y voy a dibujar otra voy a tomarme
también este color para dibujar mi
segunda recta que va a ser paralela a mi
primer recta y como son paralelas nunca
se tocan nunca se conocen y por lo tanto
mi sistema es inconsistente ahora la
pregunta es éstas dos ecuaciones que
tenemos aquí son consistentes o son
inconsistentes
para eso lo que se me ocurre hacer es
graficar estas dos ecuaciones que
tenemos aquí así que vamos en nuestro
plano cartesiano de solución de este
problema lo voy a hacer lo más grande
posible este de aquí va a ser nuestro
plano cartesiano en donde voy a graficar
estas dos rectas que yo voy a tener aquí
este es mi eje de asx este es mi eje de
leyes y vamos a empezar a trabajar con
la primera ecuación que yo tengo aquí ok
voy a buscar dos puntos porque recuerden
una cosa importantísima dados dos puntos
existe una y solamente una recta que
pasa por ellos así que si yo encuentro
dos puntos de encuentro la gráfica de
esta recta a ver qué pasa cuando
equivale 0 si x vale 0 entonces vale 13
entre 2 13 medios que esto es 6.5 o 6
enteros un medio entonces si x vale 0 no
nos movemos en el eje de las x lleva a
valer 6 medios por lo tanto este punto
tiene como coordenadas 0 13 medios y
bueno ahora qué va a pasar si lleva la 0
haciendo x igual a 0 igual a cero
encontramos los dos
y si llévale 0 x vale 13 por lo tanto no
me muevo ahora en el eje de la siesta y
voy a buscar donde que vale 13 va a ser
este punto de aquí este punto de aquí
tiene la coordenada 13,0 porque x vale
13 y llévale 0 y que creen y encontramos
dos puntos y dados dos puntos
existe una y solamente una línea recta
que pasa por ellos por lo tanto ya tengo
mi gráfica de esta ecuación en primer
lugar ahora voy a trabajar con la
segunda ecuación voy a hacer lo mismo
así que cuando x vale 0 cuanto vale y
cuando equivale 0 me queda menos y es
igual a menos 11 3 x 0 es cero y me
queda menos y es igual a menos 11 menos
y es igual a menos 11 y por lo tanto que
vale 11 si paso el signo negativo del
otro lado y entonces encuentro este
punto del 0,11 que por cierto está mucho
más arriba que el 0 6.5 por lo tanto lo
puse arriba ahora qué pasa si es igual a
cero si es igual a cero me queda que 3x
es igual a menos 11 o x es igual a menos
11 tercios y donde está menos 11 tercios
bueno es un número negativo en x por lo
tanto no puedo
poner yo en cualquier parte que esté en
dónde x vale negativo así que vámonos a
donde x vale negativo o sea como por
aquí porque menos 11 tercios es casi
menos 4 entonces va a ser este de aquí
aquí voy a tener mi segundo punto de mi
segunda ecuación que es el punto menos
11 tercios 0x vale menos 11 tercios y
lleva el día 0 y por lo tanto ya tengo
mi gráfica de mi segunda ecuación lineal
dados dos puntos existe una y solamente
una recta que pasa por ellos y que creen
ya que grafique estas dos rectas se nota
claramente que estas dos rectas se
intersectan en un punto en este punto
que está aquí tenemos un punto donde
está la recta verde la recta morada y
por lo tanto acabo de encontrar el punto
en donde se intersectan estas dos rectas
y esto quiere decir que si encontramos
al menos una solución que es este punto
donde se intersectan las dos rectas
entonces mi sistema es un sistema
consistente entonces mi respuesta es que
es un sistema consistente